no but then you know the funny thing is
right one pose can be very smart a lot
of hoes are very intelligent you don't
give a [__] yeah
all you give a [__] about is is sex and
loyalty and the whole will probably give
you sex and she can lie about being
loyal if a woman tells you her body
count is zero and she's a virgin that's
that's what you're gonna believe so no
no no no
matter it's stupid they know if you've
been single a long time
they know if you're over a certain age
like I mean I I hear I hear I hear guys
like that they like I'm friends with a
lot of guys in these spaces that give
dating advice to men and they said yeah
if a girl says she's over 25 and a
virgin don't believe her if she's been
saying I know 25 year olds that are
virgins okay okay well they could say
that but I don't know
what type of virgins you know
I really want to know what vibrator you
recommend to your friends and like the
group of people that subscribe to this
dead
because I know there's a favorite brand
I know they have a group chat and
they're like yo the the Maestro [__]
Master 3000 is [__] way better than
these men yeah that's true okay yeah can
I ask a question back to courting right
in your eyes right outside of
personality do you see men having
different value in terms of their
romantic potential to you so do you see
some that have higher some have lower
you don't know them personally but you
seem some is higher and lower foreign
not every man is seen as equal in your
eyes are they
um
he just
personality no no I'm saying Outsider
personality so I'm like for example like
if if a Matchmaker came to you said
we've got 10 guys this is what it is on
paper some you would rate higher than
others wouldn't you basically I would
probably rate bombs low okay yeah
exactly okay so you rate guys at
different values right do you understand
that men do the same for women yeah of
course okay so do you think courting
is deserving of the highest value woman
although higher value he sees her the
more he caught her I'm just asking a
question no yeah I can do you think the
higher value he sees a woman the more he
should call her
probably yeah okay but the funny thing
is so there's some women to a guy's eyes
right if he sees courting is reserved
for the highest value woman in his eyes
there'll be some women that he sees
that's not worth quoting yeah definitely
of course okay that's all we're saying
no I know when people say she's for the
streets they don't wanna exactly no I
hear everything you guys are saying okay
but it doesn't change the fact that a
hoe whatever you define as a hoe
is deserving of courting and she will be
courted by someone who she might not be
quoted by you but trust me
yeah she's a premium man than most
virgins no no no no probably more
premium men than most people okay okay
so so you're right on some level hoes do
a very good job of hiding it a lot of
the time and they do end up getting
married a lot of the time but the issue
and I've asked a lot of older people
this like I've asked people like in
their 40s 50s like what happens to the
hoes they get married eventually they
say yeah but they're the first divorced
I want to go back to like what you said
about how virgins are 80 more likely to
stay
um married yeah well they're more likely
to rate their marriages happy after 10
years oh so it's actually happy because
that's that's a big question are they
actually even happily married well all
you can do you know they say believe
women so if we ask them and they say
they're happy
do you not believe women so this is
false
no my question would be seriously are
they actually happy after but we believe
women here so yeah if they say they're
happy that's really cool I still don't
think I've got an answer to a question
though which question so it sounds it
sounds to me at this stage that I know
you're speaking on behalf of women but
it sounds that's what you said but it
sounds like no you did not I'm speaking
on behalf of myself
you've said that you're speaking on
behalf of women it sounds to me like
you're speaking more on behalf of
yourself I've never said I was speaking
last one but so let's go back to my
original question okay you said every
woman deserves to be coated okay yes now
if a man my own opinion right but if a
man but you've also said courtship
obviously being dating without sex but
you've also said that women and men can
date and you've you just agreed recently
a man and a woman can it can lead to a
relationship if a man and a woman has
sex while they're dating so why the [__]
is a man gonna waste all of it was am I
going to waste all of those all of those
resources that time and energy on
courting you with no guarantee of six at
the end when you can just date you have
six at the same time and get the same
loyalty and sustainable at the end so he
can date someone else and have sex
because if you're gonna Court me we're
not gonna have sex because I'm not gonna
just sleep with you you've just gone
back on your statement yeah but then
like why why wouldn't he just I'm trying
to answer your question he's saying why
have you gone back earlier because you
said that someone can date you and have
sex but you're saying oh he's awesome
in general okay
you can't date me and just have sex and
it and I will hope that one day it
releases the relationship right that
can't happen respectfully respectfully
forget you for a second that's why yeah
that's what people yeah or women in
general yeah you can date and it can
lead to a relationship for other women
but the reason why I don't think that's
right is because that can is not a
hundred percent so I don't think it's
right it's not 100 that's going to lead
to a relation
that's fine but at the same time it's
also not a guarantee that a man will get
six at the end of courtship so it sounds
like you want to have your cake and eat
it yeah
and the thing is right yeah because a
man should be putting in more effort and
should be risking more because men need
women more than women
you can feel it you can feel it but you
can you can okay okay okay you got it
you gotta stop over talking me you can
you can feel it but if historically 40
of men have reproduced so the majority
of men have lived without women always
can I ask yeah let's just go back before
you skip you just were saying that
this is what you feel should be like you
don't want your hold out from sex you'll
hold out you hold out but you expect you
this you expect this you expect this but
now today like Society women just give
out sex and so that's why I said the
value of sexes and the value of vagina
is in the ground because women give it
up but the point of the matter is so let
me finish here the point of the matter
is you're talking about why women should
be courted and the whole debate is why
women shouldn't be basically like
because we're not deserving of it or
what type of woman should be oh God and
you're saying you want to be and that's
fine but that we're talking about debate
about Society about women in general
like why why should I wish
think about why women should be better
for them okay okay
but uh but the but the problem is you
can't just raise your value for if
you've given it out before like you want
to be courted Like a Virgin but if
you're not a virgin how can you ask for
Virgin prices you can't put a higher
price tag and what you've given yeah
like so so you can't just say you can't
just say I am valuable like I could say
I'm a billionaire it doesn't make me a
billion millionaire so if you're not a
virgin anymore you can you can say give
me virgin prices but if you're not a
virgin you can't just magically become
one you know I think I think I think she
actually I think she actually agrees
because you literally just said right
you're just like
every you wish women you said the value
of vagina is in the ground right because
sex is giving out too easily for a bunch
of women right so you're saying you feel
you deserve you feel that women deserve
to be quoted if they were going to raise
the value of vagina if they acted well
right so in actual fact so you're
actually agreeing saying that the Modern
Woman today Ryan averages lower value so
then she actually doesn't deserve it but
the thing is right the value of vagina
can never ever go down because men will
always decide whether it does no no no
but it's only down because it's not a
zero yeah it's only down because it's so
readily available if women all of a
sudden if the government put into place
that no man can have sex until he puts
down 100K deposits what do you think men
would do they would uh the government
and
and you can't make you younger like you
can't you can't just raise someone's
value you can't make you younger you
can't make you more pure there's new
girls turning 21 every single day as
many of you
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible